good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please allow me
to welcome you to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series this lecture series is supported
by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
i'm absolutely delighted to introduce our speaker
today dr aidong zhang here from the university of
virginia here in charlottesville virginia edong
earned her phd from purdue university in 1994
and is currently the william wolf faculty
fellow and professor of computer science
with joint appointments in the department of
biomedical engineering and the school of data
science here at the university of virginia her
research interests focus on machine learning
data mining bioinformatics and health informatics
she has served as the editor-in-chief of the ieee
transactions in computational biology and
bioinformatics journal she's the founding chair of
the acm special interest group in bioinformatics
computational biology and biomedical informatics
where she served from 2011 to 2015 and she's
currently the chair of its advisory board
she's a founding and steering chair
of the acm international conference
on bioinformatics computational biology and
health informatics and served in that role
from 2010 until fairly recently in 2019 again her
research interests involve machine learning data
mining bioinformatics and health informatics
and specifically dr zhang develops data mining
and uh deep learning machine learning approaches
to modeling and the analysis of structured
and unstructured data with a variety of
applications especially as it pertains to
biomedical applications as is the theme of this
year's um biomedical data science innovation lab
um dr zhang's presentation today is entitled
metal learning for biological knowledge transfer
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube and if you're watching
on youtube thank you so much for joining us today
also our specially selected 2020 2021 biomedical
data science innovation app participants are
very much encouraged to submit any questions
for dr zhang via the chat feature in their zoom
sessions i'll synthesize these questions and ask
them on your behalf during the last 10 minutes
or so of the lecture and with that welcome a dong
thank you so much for doing this we're really
looking forward to hearing your presentation
thank you jack thank you for inviting me to be
here and uh i hope you know i can be helpful for
your lab so anyway uh so today um i will focus on
the uh machine learning part uh for bioinformatics
and health informatics so hope uh to talk
about new things which may be helpful uh to the
lab people so first of all i hope uh to mention
that the machine learning and deep learning
has been popularly used in bioinformatics
and due to multi-omics data in different
you know cases like a cancer or other diseases
so we have uh plenty of data available uh so
uh so people start to use the
machine learning deeper and new
to the main purpose of using that or the
main function this can do is to integrate
different modality data into a uniform
representation and you can do prediction so
with that we start to think about you know
what are the challenges in this direction
so so to apply the deep learning into
this uh medical and uh biomedical domain
we do have a very challenging problem which is
called the big p small n problem so so what do we
have is we we have an enormous amount of data but
each cohort so we normally have a small number of
samples but each example has a high dimensional
features uh so that's called a big p small n
problem and and moreover you know in in the image
with the images so you have a spatial relationship
but as also a convolutional neural network
normally can work well with with that
but in in the general omics data you don't have
that spatial relationship in the input data
so so these are challenges to apply the the
dependent approaches in bio biomedical field
so uh with those challenges our goal
is to design uh you know uh design
uh not normal models that can accurately
uh predict uh based on the less training
data so that's our goal how to predict based
on the the small amount of training data so
uh you know it turns out that normally we
can do this customize the deep learning
that can incorporate some domain knowledges into
the more accurate uh prediction so so with that
i just hope to mention one people we published
in the top ai conference the top triple ai
we published the paper which shows how to utilize
both labeled and unlabeled data to train a deep
learning model to make a accurate prediction so
in there the central idea is to how to make a
attention putting layers inside of deep learning
to make the the model faster in converging to uh
to a prediction model so that's one of the recent
work we have done but today i hope to talk about
the new things in machine learning and how this
can be applied to you know our field and we can
design some some uh projects in the lab uh coming
in june so so the new trend here so currently
if you you have gotten into the deep learning
so you you know you know in order to train
a different new model you need a large
amount of data to do this but uh we as i said
we don't have that much data in each cohort so
although we have a lot of data in general but
then we look at how human man thinks you know even
a kid does not learn things with a huge amount of
data so you can learn things very quickly you know
if you know you how to ride a bike you you can
write a motorcycle you know learn
how to write a motorcycle very fast
and if you've seen cat and bird you can easily
you know just a couple of times you can easily uh
quickly you know tell them apart so this is
a human so it turns out that you see human
uh does not learn things based on a lot of
samples just a few samples and in reality in
biomedical field you do have the scenario you know
you have a big data but it's a long tail uh shape
so small data are more common so with that um you
know the machine learning field has advanced a lot
and so uh i hope to show what people are thinking
right now so so so basically you have a few images
and then you just want to train you know tell
show you this is a bird this is a dog this is cat
and then you can giving a dog and bird you can
see this is a dog this is a cat right and in
our biomedical domain if we have a few samples in
different diseases and then give you a new patient
you want to be able to detect whether this
person is this disease or that disease so
so this latter with limited training data so what
is our uh you know go here the the the interesting
research you know has been going on is
transferring so to transfer uh you know knowledge
from other domains to the domain you don't have
much data so transferring has been going on a lot
so the latest device is a metadata so learning
how to transfer so that is one of the things um
we we we look at it so what is the matter
right now uh so mediterranean uh as the new
uh research topic in the con the machine
learning domain it's saying we want to
mimic human learning by training a
machine model on different learning tasks
so but each task only has a few samples
okay and then so the machine can learn
to quickly adapt to the environment with new
tasks so that's basically what we are training
the machine so to mimic how human learn so uh to
change such a model to quickly adapt with a few
few examples and that is a a lot of challenge
how you will do it right how you will do it
so uh a good uh so there are there are different
i will skip this one how we will to to next one
so how we do it so uh basically i want to use
this example i borrowed from a blog you know
it's a good example to show how this works and uh
here as an examination rather than going through
the uh the formal you know processes so basically
you have uh you know if you are familiar with the
machine learning models you train the model using
a lot of data now i don't give you uh you know a
lot of data to train mode i give you a lot of
tasks so you can have a thousand thousand tasks
but each task has a training superset um and a
query set so for example training task line has a
this is called n equal to three means n way which
is a number of classes so you have three classes
k two means uh uh two samples
so each class has two samples
even anyway uh two two chart so this is a uh
what the when people saying anyway so each task
i only have two samples in each process i have
three classes and the query said this has a one
from each class okay so then the class the
training task the two can have a totally different
samples from the task line so for example you can
see here are the darkest uh dolphin and lines so
these are very different from the task line so so
you have a thousand such tasks to train you model
and then you have to test the task similarly
you have a sub percent and you have a query set
okay so with that uh so you train
the so so each time you use a task
and and then you use the query so the machine can
look at the the support set and the query said
to quickly adapt to detect the query set and then
you use the second task to quickly adapt so uh in
the end the model is not trained for any specific
task it's trending in general to detect to adapt
to the new uh environment so when you train the
your model can do this then when giving you a
query task with only a few samples then you can
quickly adapt the model to detect when given clear
okay so that's generally what the matter learning
means so it's trying to mimic how human learn
so with that i hope to mention there are
different versions of meta learning uh
you know in the coming from the machine learning
community so the memo is the most famous one uh
from berkeley and uh and then you have a few
charter learning methods uh these are all
different methods and so i will use the meta memo
as an example uh to show to to show how it works
so so basically uh i as i said you train the model
to quickly adapt so what does that mean in terms
of the parameters in the model specifically so
you can see here if this is what we want to train
right and then using those uh support tasks
we quickly adapted to each environment
this small delta errors you can quickly so with
this adaptation quickly you train this data so
eventually after the training you got a theta
which is your matter running after method and
the model which is supposed to be able to quickly
adapt to your environment so then after that
when you are given new tasks so with just a few
samples the sita can uh quickly adapt to stata one
star city two two-star series three stars in
different environment so if you're familiar with
the transfer learning this is a similar uh concept
that means we will learn a good theta in the model
which can easily adapt or fast adapter to
different environment okay so hope that it's
clear on what the basic idea of what the material
is um recently so measuring here has been applied
to computer vision a lot uh so very popular
approach so but recently in the past two or
three years it has started to to be used in the
biomedical domain so here i uh i referenced the
two papers they showed the uh metal lining
out performs uh regular transfer menu in
their paper and with data the second one
has a a significant work from stanford um so
basically they are showing the metal renew using
methadone you can transfer the knowledge from
uh different cell types uh so you can adapt it to
new cell types with just a few uh samples okay so
uh i would specifically mention this paper because
you know you're doing a neural uh neural related
research in this lab so so this paper applied the
metadata to the alzheimer's disease so basically
uh this paper oh so i'm using their slides
so it seems automatically moving so this
slide uh they actually use the amnesia and
the dimitri and the parkinson's uh samples
as their support dot me and then you you they use
the mci which is very close to alzheimer as the
support and then uh so to train the model using
this is three uh uh samples which are similar
but you know in the same category but a different
kind of different disease to train the model to
extract the the common uh the parameter which can
quickly adapt then eventually use the alzheimer
so that's what they they design so in uh so back
to to the to the page to the slide so in this uh
you know they have a slightly different design
because they use the mci which is a more closer to
the alzheimer's to as a tester's domain to first
train the model and then adapt it to alzheimer's
so in their paper uh uh so they use the two so
here's the data they used uh from oregon health
and uh so the you can see from the data set they
have a dementia and measure so these are all not a
lot of data so case and control so each of them
you know you won't be able to you know train a
deep learning model with each individual
cohort but uh with the way designed here
uh using the source domain to train them to to
train the metadata model they are able to use this
initial and dementia data to train the
common parameters which you can quickly adapt
to the alzheimer's disease okay so this is a
whether they experimented so with their result
departed from the paper so they they compared
with a lot of uh supervised uh learning models uh
so including all this logistical regression k n uh
random forest so so these are all popular approach
uh people use and then you they also use
some other basic uh metal renewal approach
and they show the uh so their uh metal cnn and the
metal error as tm so you added the metal learning
uh process into the model on top of cnn lc ls
tm will do much better uh in the prediction of
diseases so so they they they show the result
like like that so uh so so so the this work uh
showed that uh the metal renew is effective in
the biomedical applications so with that uh we
also published the paper uh you know to show how
meta-renewal works for tcga so if you're familiar
with the tcga this cancer genomic adolescence
so it has uh over two to twenty thousand primary
uh cases uh cancer samples uh both control and
and uh disease cases and they have plenty of
features so they have genomic they have
epigenomic transcript atomic all pro
proteomic they have all these features so so
the features are enormous it's a high dimension
but if you look at the although
they have a 20 000 samples but
if you look at the each category of the
cancer so these are different cancers in there
so they have a 33 different type of cancer
but if you look at the each cancer the the
the samples are quite small the largest is just
over a thousand so it is not practical to train
any of these cancers using the differential model
because the the samples are too small right so uh
so so how do we uh you know utilize this in in
prediction models so we look at it carefully and
so so you have all these different data types and
features and then we we apply so so our goal is to
to perform cancer prediction so so here uh
so we in order to do that we utilize the
uh label the the samples from different cancer set
and so for example here you have a the brca cancer
you have a this uh gbm cancer and this different
so these are the phone name of the cancer
and then applying the same method uh process so
we train uh so so we form a different set of tasks
with each different kind of cancer we
can form small tasks and and then we can
train the metal renewal model and do matter
tests and and then form a model which can
uh quickly pre adapt to the new cancers so that's
the the idea so you know a little bit more deal i
i i'm not going to show the the formulas but i
will show this picture to illustrate the idea
so so basically in in in the episode is the term
they use the in the machine learning community so
in each of the inner group you you train
the model using tasks so these tasks
are from different cancers so each cancer you
probably use just a few samples and then you can
train it to quickly adapt to the to the query to
predict the query and then in the in the outer
group you use the uh different tasks to test and
then it can so so so this train this uh stata will
adapt quickly with the new uh testing cases and
then with that you you gotta so you you gradually
train a good theta which is you can use to adapt
to any new cancers okay so so this is a what uh
is applied to the to the tcga using the
mediterranean framework uh with that so the
trinium setup in our environment uh so we have uh
all these different data so we use the 31 cancers
from the so so there are two i think too small
and all another you know good cases to be used
so we we randomly selected 21 cancels and then we
use the validation randomly selected five cancels
and then the test in case we randomly see like
five cancels and so so with that the result
we tested with different features so first
using just the proteomic features as the
the features of the samples and then we we have
this many patients from 31 cancers and three way
five way means that we use three classes to train
the model and it means three cancers each time and
one shot means each time you have three classes
one sample in the class and three shot means
three classes three samples all five classes one
sample and five samples okay so with a different
scenario we see how it works so we compare them
with different metal and new method and also pain
and random forest and uh so we use the so mammal
based uh performed the best in the scenario so
these two the metro network and the pro
uh prototypical network also are metal new
methods but it looks like a mammal based it
works the best so here you can also see when you
have more samples in each class it does perform
better so this one has five samples in each class
and you train the model it does perform better so
that makes sense rather you have more samples in
in each task you can train model better so these
are remarkable uh you know result from uh using
the meta renew to do the prediction um so we also
use the um you know more different you know set of
features for example this one we we also
including the rna expression data so we have
more features and then did this so with these
features the more features uh included it looks
it's performing better and even reaching 98
accuracy in here so uh that feature and uh if
we also use the all features including everything
in tcga the available features then actually the
performance dropper a little bit because so so
you can see some of the features are not useful or
duplicated or noisy so so we we saw those noises
so so this is what uh is showing with that so so
uh it is uh quite in you know encouraging to use
the method to extract common uh you know good
transferring capabilities to transfer to new
cancers uh in this way so we've shown that other
people also shown that so with that you know
the current research whether current research
we are interested in so we want to not only just
purely use the methodology uh approach you know uh
the machine learning community design we also want
to uh integrate the knowledge from the biomedical
domains so the issue is how you will integrate
the domain knowledges into this process and uh so
one thing we can look at is domain knowledge from
the back graphs so for example in in image you can
have this hierarchical graph mammal to dog a dog
have different dog cat they have different type
so from patient data you know just look at the
uh nervous system you will have a different kind
of uh disorder or degenerative nervous system
and alzheimer's so this belongs to different
categories so you do have such a ontology uh as
knowledge you can use and you can incorporate that
into the systems so uh so so with that we look
at the you know mimic data so mimic data is uh
clinical data so these are you know including
mostly the icd-9 diagnosis called uh and lab
lab testing uh result so uh mimic data has a lot
of disease and a lot of features too uh to be used
so with that we the reason we use this is
because the mimik data they call the the
coded based on the uh disease so so the code
actually indicated whether uh other categories
so so for example nerve they have three numbers
and go to four number this is indicating different
diseases so in the hierarchy so we can utilize
we utilize this uh in the metal immune system
and to to to narrow down our uh so so so i will
not go to detail this is a kdd uh paper uh in
20 paper we published so i will just show
some result so with those knowledge integrated
into the process we can we can show that uh
so this is a tada net is the one we included
into that learning model so we can search
we can we can narrow to the different
ontology relationship so to utilize
those relationship uh you can see
uh our approach perform better than mammal so
previously we showed the memo based approach
how to perform this uh approaches uh matching
network prototype so you can see they basically
memo works better than this in the example but
ours works much better because we utilize the
domain knowledge in the process so here sample
sub graph sampling means we sample the data
in based on the sub graph definition so if
you only sample based on so so here and random
sampling uh cases so here is what it means if
i sample the tasks based on the sub graphs so
then they are more similar it's more difficult to
distinguish between them so if you randomly sample
among the graphs then they are more far away
easier to distinguish so in that sense why
when you use a subgraph sampling we get lower
accuracy than random sampling so but we wanted
to show you know with different strategies and
with the graph integrated how much it affects
the results so so this is what we
get with that okay so if you want to
uh learn more details you can look at the paper
this is a kdt 2020 paper um so with that uh
let me see um we we also uh so so this is a
the the mimic data we have this predefined
ontology but i mentioned the uh the cancer
data and we want to apply the cancer you know
some kind of ontology on the cancer
data too so this i just want to mention
uh the cancer also has maybe not a predefined
ontology but they have based on the data set
you can build hierarchy with the data so
we did not do that but i hope to find out
if you are interested you can look into this
how to build the ontology based on the the data
in the tcga for this purpose because there is
no predefined relationship between the cancers
in general so you have to build based
on specific data so this is a potential
interesting research people can look into um so uh
lastly before i finish my talk i also to mention
a potential uh research you know for the lab
people can think about which may be interesting
to you because this can be applied to both cancer
and alzheimer's or other diseases so that is
how to apply the metabolic approach for survival
analysis so so basically uh the survivor analysis
uh have some unique features so the deep learning
may be good to apply so so for example in the tcga
pan cancer data set or you in the ad admin and
adsp disease dataset so you have a lot of features
and you have a lot of samples and you also
have this uh survivor data indicated when
the the the sample died and but the challenging
issue is you have probably 78 percent are censored
so censored means the the subject leaves before
event occurs so you don't know when they died so
or when they had the alzheimer's disease they left
early so those in the uh survival analysis the
domain is called the sensor data so in so in the
in the in the uh you know survivor analysis has
been going on for a long long time so there are
many survival models cox is the most famous model
uh so the issue is how to integrate those models
into the metadata process so the basic concept you
have the censored and uncensored patient so if you
only use the uncensored patients which you know
when the event happened then that's more
accurate but the the problem is like as i said
you know most of the data sets don't have the
that information so you so how do you deal with
such a sensor data you probably don't want to
just get rid of it because they then you lose
a lot of the information so here we we
actually uh propose the to use deep learning
to directly learn a survival distribution
from data not using the cox model because
you can you can learn the the uh distribution
just the you know utilizing the best uh you know
time they they left so when they left and a sample
left earlier than another sample you can consider
uh that has a a a different the time of a event
may happen so the later one will have a bad you
know a later sum so using those relationship
we can uh learn using different new model
for the sensor data make a a a prediction
of the distribution so that's what we we we
uh currently working on so so basically uh so
since uh uh you know patients live up to the
censored time so so we just in in our uh deep
learning model we just you use the log like
there's a survival probability before censoring
time as the log likelihood so so we are maximizing
whether we know based on the data then we we
use ranking to to rank the relative risk of
patients so that's uh so how we we deal with the
censored samples in fact there are other papers
they recently show uh this can perform better
than the cox model uh utilizing this censored data
in the uh survival analysis so this is uh
what uh we do so in the model i will not
go uh details about uh the model but uh we we will
so so so basically in the formula we will indicate
which are the sensors which are non-sensor and
then we can build the optimization function
to learn the distribution based on the data
so that's what we have with how we handle the
the survival model part so uh with that uh so
the metal uh survivor lanyard so in order to
incorporating that into the uh you know
metal menu so we we have a uh you know
as i mentioned the metal revenue and the base
learning models i introduced the uma they can
train and and to be able to adapt to the new
environment so but in order to integrate the
survival analysis into the meta renewal so
in the metal survivor the survival model
is designed so survival model is as a baseliner
so you learn the basic survival analysis
based on what i just mentioned so we
should so you you will make a predictions
for different patients with different cancers
for example or alzheimer's diseases and uh
so and then using the same principle the
survival model will faster adapt to the
prediction context so it's a similar principle
the only difference is that you train that
survival model inside of uh big the uh the
metal randy so um so so then the prediction made
by the survivor will continue on a specific
disease under uh the metal renewal uh process
so uh so so that's the the the general idea
so now here we are what we are working on here
is we try to use knowledge more into the matter
a survivor model so so we we have a so now more
customized here not a very general because in
terms of the biomedical so we build a knowledge
repository uh which you know indicating so the
related samples okay so the samples uh in a
customized way from the repository so to cons
construct some context so in order so so that
if we can construct some such a context for
survival uh prediction then we can make a better
uh prediction model so specifically uh two kind
of uh the sample knowledge or context we build
the first one is difficulty awareness so this we
can recognize you know prediction difficulty of a
given patient sample related to other samples in
the repository so uh so so we have the set of uh
patients then we can assign attention so if you
have learned this attention model in in the nlp
modeling so we assign attention to each of
these samples so we build a sample set which
you know to realize the context of difficulty
in the samples and in addition to that we also
uh indicating the heterogeneity awareness
which identifies how a given sample is
different from other samples in the repository so
and please so then place the survival model at a
proper position uh in its a parameter space so so
these are the current contacts that we considered
model uh so um so uh so to be a little bit
specific this is a general framework we
we have been building uh uh in our meta survival
analysis with knowledge so we we so so here you
can see here uh i strongly believe the knowledge
from the biomedical domain can play a very big law
in the machine learning process so and how much of
this you can generalize to different uh you know
different domains of diseases that's a a different
issue but the general framework should be able
to apply to different domains so so basically
on the left of this figure you can see we can
we can track the context of samples and with
the graph of the knowledge in the domain and
then we can you know integrate this into
our training of the meta learning process
and and so with difficulty and the heterogeneity
then also we incorporate the so we can incorporate
the survival model and into this process
so that's currently what we are building uh
for the survival analysis model so we have some
results but i do not have the tables to to report
you know a complete table to be part here but i i
strongly believe in covering the domain knowledge
is very effective to build a better uh
metal a new model for knowledge transfer
okay so that's mostly uh i hope
here they encourage some of the
you know some of the interest into this research
for the lab um so now i so i'm going to finish up
with my slide here so basically in a
conclusion so if we demonstrated a bit
the ability of metal length uh memo and other uh
parts so how to predict cancer type and survival
survival time so that's so then with this we can
build a model that can classify rare cancers so
that's the main point to classify the rare cancers
with new subtypes you obtain just a few samples
you can quickly adapt it to the new samples but i
should point out that there's still a long way to
go there are many interesting problem in health
and bio informatics for which so the new machine
learning methods can help i i do think that the
new uh machine learning methods can help but uh
it it does need both you know the very close
collaboration between the computer scientists
and the domain experts so that you know we can uh
incorporating domain knowledge into the prediction
models so that's the whole point that i hope to
make here since the lab has both data scientists
and biomedical uh domain people so i i think you
know working closely between the two sides we can
generate a good ideas and the results so uh with
that i hope to mention some of the acknowledgement
so basically the nsf support and also my
students who contributed to this presentation
so i basically finished the on
the based on the budgeted time
i will be able to answer some questions hey
dong thank you so much that was uh wonderful
uh really great synopsis of of uh it's kind
of meta learning uh applications and and you
covered a lot of ground thank you so much um
one of the things which i was kind of wondering
as you were presenting is when you kind of know
beforehand what your training samples happen to be
um you know like where you have the different
types of cancers or for example you know your
your early example of looking at the faces of
animals or something and trying to identify kind
of how what's the minimum amount you need in order
to kind of get the meta learning thing started
nevertheless you kind of have to kind of specify
a priori at the same time that's kind of a static
you know that's a static data set in a sense and
then you hope to be able to apply it later on to
you know new exemplars i guess where i'm going
with this question is this almost seems like it
would have a lot of applicability in streaming
information as you're getting information it's
kind of like flowing in um to a system and being
able to in a very quick amount of time begin the
meta bootstrapping the metal learning process and
then being able to uh perform classifications as
data is streaming in do you have any ideas
about how you might apply that and you know
there's a you know number of like biomedical or
neuropsyc neuro um neuro scientific data types
that might be like that that might be very
appropriate for a modeling system like this
does that make sense but that
that's an interesting question
so basically you're thinking you have a
streaming data so uh but are you assuming
the streaming data will will be new type
new type of data or is the same data uh it
would like be well you know for example uh it
might be electroencephalographic data so it's
uh multiple channels of electrical activity coming
you know from someone's brain could one uh build
a meta learning system that starts reading that
in and starts using it as it's streaming in you
know the person's performing or behaving or
thinking or there's mental activity going on
and the system could use that information to
perform meta learning about generalized things
but then when asked to do specific things the
model might adapt and learn from it itself yeah
that's a very interesting uh you know thinking
because i i haven't seen people doing that but
you know in principle uh you have a you
are streaming you have a different type of
you know data coming right so you can
form uh tasks you know in terms of tasks
different different tasks and to extract the most
common features among these tasks right and then
then you can quickly you know jump into the
new data coming and you can make a prediction
that's what i'm kind of wondering is you
could like have the system just start
not knowing anything and just start reading
the stream and as you know there's you know
different tasks or something are happening um
it might be able to learn the general principles
and then you could you know you could build up
a knowledge base of how that stream should be
coming and interpreted and then you could throw
curveballs at it meaning you could change the
tasks slightly and see if how quickly it adapts
to the new task yeah i i i think it can work
you know but it doesn't need to experiment well
of course yeah i think in principle it should
you know it's a possible
it's a potential application
yeah just you know thinking about that as
a possibility um also uh what you mentioned
that can also be kind of used to um take look
at images um you gave an example of course of
of animals i'm curious if you've attempted
to apply this to um any say microscopy
data the data coming from microscopes to do uh
you know look at different cell types or something
yeah yeah we did not do that yet but uh certainly
this is a one kind of application you can do
yeah i mean there's pl there's plenty of that data
around so it would be kind of interesting to see
it apply yeah um and another uh thing would
be like in human neuroimaging where you have
time series data for example or you have
different subjects uh different patient
groups for example um and being able to use this
to try to classify some of the neural imaging data
yeah that's uh actually so uh in the computer
vision domain originally this proposed
was used for those common images or different
images so i think it will be uh you know very
likely to be affected effective in those
you know images you just mentioned yeah hey
don what do you see as being an important
element for biomedical scientists where
data scientists can play an important role
uh i guess yeah that's a very important question
so in fact i just taught a class for biomedical
department they created this new course
called data mining and machine learning for
bio medical engineers so yeah i just finished that
course and i believe there is a gap be you know
between the data scientists and the biomedical
uh researchers uh because i i feel uh the
the the the tools biomedical data biomedical
scientists use are still very basic basic tools
and and so mostly you know uh statistical
oriented tools so i believe there is a gap between
how much you can use you know from the
machine learning data science aside to the
biomedical research so that neither really
needs both side work very close in the
problem solving i think yeah i appreciated
your comment uh there in your conclusions
and you have it up on the screen now that uh that
close collaboration is really important between
computer scientists data scientists people doing
analysis um so that these machine learning methods
can be kind of incorporated that those prediction
models actually mean something and the predictions
are are valuable but you're not going to you're
not going to get that unless there's close
collaboration and team science kind of approach
would you agree yeah yeah fantastic well with
that uh aidong zhang from here at the university
of virginia thank you so much for sharing your
work with us today that was really fantastic um
for everyone who joined us uh thank you so much
for doing so um everybody have a wonderful weekend
and we'll see you next week for our final in this
series of biomedical data science innovation
lab seminar series take care everybody bye